bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you
subscribe to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to eight point six percent
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral you can use the description
right here
or you can go to blockfi.com to learn
more
all right let's get in this episode i
hope you guys enjoy this one
[Music]
all right guys bang bang i've got will
here with me thank you so much for doing
this man
thanks so much for having me on super
excited for sure
so uh you are unlike most of my guests
in that you are 18 years old i think
you are a finance major uh at the
uh east carolina university um but talk
us through kind of your background
where'd you grow up
how did you get into finance bitcoin
yeah sure so i grew up in the raleigh
north carolina area
i really had no interest in finance
until right around march of this year
when the markets tanked
i was like oh maybe i could make some
some easy money here because everything
was cheap
i started listening to a couple
different podcasts um i got into kind of
the discount cash flow based uh
investing
and what i realized was that when you're
when you're doing those kind of
free cash flow based analysis on a
company you're making this
uh assumption that there's sound money
um and that's a premise that
not a lot of value investors really talk
about i think
but when i realized that it kind of
clicked to me why growth and
momentum investing strategies have
outperformed value over the last couple
years
and you know you can't fight the fed and
when they're printing this much money
what you need to be doing is buying some
kind of scarce asset
and that really led me to bitcoin and um
the fact that bitcoin is the scarcest
asset that's on the market right now
yeah so uh you and i don't know each
other we uh we didn't even know each
other existed in the world
uh the only commonality we have is that
we both grew up in the raleigh area
but i originally came over or became
aware of you
when i saw one of the pieces that you
put out very early on
um as you started to write more and more
on the internet and i was just really
impressed i think with
the quality and the intellectual rigor
that you put into into the piece so what
i want to do today
uh is i'm going to throw out the titles
of a number of the different pieces that
you've written
uh over the last few months and i want
you basically just to give us a summary
a summary of what is the piece about and
kind of what are the takeaways for
people who don't have time to go read
all of them
um and then we'll finish up with the
latest article that you re that you
wrote does that sound good
awesome all right awesome so uh let's
just start with
the first one that i saw which is why is
bitcoin important i think there's a lot
of people who think it's important but
like
what exactly is your thought process as
to why bitcoin is important
sure so the the first thing to really
note is that uh
the macro backdrop that has kind of uh
taken place over the last
you know and i guess you could say since
2008 with quantitative easing
uh liquidity being inserted through the
fixed income market
um and interest rates being driven to to
pretty much zero and now we're starting
to see
a little bit of ubi this isn't the same
sustainable forever
and in my opinion bitcoin kind of is is
the solution to that problem
and so when you think through it being
the solution why exactly is it the
solution
yeah sure so bitcoin you know there's
only 21 million that will
will ever exist every four years that uh
the rate of new flow coming onto the
market is cut in half
and so there's nothing really out there
that that is like that you know
when we think about gold um
if gold's price goes up the producers
will just step into the market
and and start producing more of it
they'll find new ways to extract it
make new technologies you know if the
monetary incentive through
the price going up is there they'll find
new ways to
produce more more gold and that will uh
drive the
the price of gold back to its mean and
and so for bitcoin the idea that there's
this fixed supply is really just kind of
a revolutionary idea in financial
markets that
there'll there's finally a constant um
in other disciplines even like for
example physics you have
a constant of the speed of light and we
don't have any kind of constant like
that in finance and having some kind of
hard supply cap and programmatic um
monetary policy is something that really
uh brought my attention to bitcoin
so you you also write up uh you have
written a piece
about why this bitcoin cycle is
differently you compared a lot of what's
going on right now
to pass market cycles both the bull and
bear market so explain why you think
this uh cycle specifically is different
yeah sure so
when you look at the early days of
bitcoin it was really kind of um
driven by cypherpunks and people that
were savvy with uh
cryptography and then in 2013 you had
malcox and and
the aftermath of the compromise of that
exchange
and then in 2017 it was really retail
driven and you can kind of see that on
chain where
coins on exchanges was steadily going up
with price
throughout that time and then in this
recent cycle what what really
differentiate
differentiates it for me is the fact
that coins are being pulled off
exchanges and you can see that on chain
by looking at
kind of this dramatic slope downwards
and
i think that's driven by a couple things
the first thing is that people are just
understanding more of the importance of
of cold storage and taking custody of
your coins especially
institutions that are piling in huge
sums of money and they're not going to
play around with having this
counterparty risk
and the other thing as well is that
miners have completely stopped selling
and you can see that on chain as well
they've actually started accumulating
even a marathon who i think a lot of
people are familiar with they've come
out publicly and said that
they've started accumulating and the
third driver i think of of
the coins being pulled off exchanges is
this concept that's uh been made
popularized by
preston pitch and plan b and that's
this whole concept of over
collateralization and and
people taking advantage of uh arbitrage
spreads through
the difference between spot price and
the
futures price that's trading at a
premium so right now
i don't have it in front of me but if
you look at the futures price it's
trading at a multi
thousand dollar uh premium to the
current price and and
it's interesting because commodities
traditionally trade at premiums but it's
because they have storage costs for
example like with
with oil but bitcoin has no no storage
cost because it's digital
and and so to kind of just speculate
there's no way to know for sure but
it possibly is because there's
regulatory uh restrictions that are
allowing certain inc
that aren't allowing certain
institutions to get exposure to spot
bitcoin
and they may be doing that through the
futures market
the other thing as well is that it's
really easy to get leverage through
through the futures market so those are
the two reasons that i think um
whether it's one or the other
combination of the two
that's driving this uh premium in the
futures price
and so people are looking to capture
these arbitrage spreads on an annualized
basis
on an annualized basis they're trading
at like 14
15 percent right now and and when they
go to capture these spreads
they have to lock up these coins because
they have to borrow the coins from a
lender such as block fi
and block fire requires um
like the loans are collateralized with
the 50
ltv which means if i'm borrowing 50
50 worth of um bitcoin i have to post
100
is of collateral and then block flight
takes that hundred dollars
and then they transfer it into bitcoin
to kind of eliminate some of the
counterparty risk for the person on the
other end
that's lending their coins out to who's
borrowing them
and they turn the turn the collateral
into bitcoin to be held in escrow until
uh the borrower is is able to pay off
the loan
and so what this is essentially doing is
it's locking up more coins
out of supply than would have naturally
taken place
through uh the natural supply having if
you will
and i think those those three factors
between
people just flat out uh understanding
cold storage and having an importance on
that
minor stop selling and then that over
collateralization uh to capture those
arbitrage spreads i think those
three things are really what's driving
that uh this supply that's being pulled
off of exchanges
for sure and so when you think about uh
kind of bitcoin you've talked a lot
about this
idea of a bitcoin renaissance as well
this is the third piece that you wrote
uh explain what you mean by that bitcoin
renaissance
yeah sure so i think sound money is
really important
um throughout the last 10 years we've
really started to see a lot of social
unrest especially
last year and i think that's kind of
indirectly related to the fact that
people are getting behind via the
inflationary
monetary policy that's going on and they
don't understand why
you know they're fed up with the system
they know something's wrong but they
don't know exactly what it is
a lot of people point fingers at
capitalism but in my opinion what it
really is
is the inflationary monetary policy and
the amount of money printing that the
fed's doing right
um if you don't own an asset then you
can't get ahead in the current
environment if you're holding
just money in savings over time you're
getting destroyed through
through the money that the government's
just printing especially throughout the
last 12 months when they've printed
trillions and trillions of dollars
and so i think when you introduce a
sound money particularly
one that's deflationary like bitcoin you
really incentivize saving
and you allow people to be able to get
ahead again
and so that that's what i really meant
by saying that uh
bitcoin would kind of introduce this new
renaissance is that
in the current in the current
environment there's a lot of people that
are just getting destroyed and they're
behind and they're if you think about it
they're running on this hamster wheel
and everything the world is expanding
around them and it's becoming more and
more out of reach
because everything around them is
becoming more expensive
and under a bitcoin standard people who
own bitcoin and just hold bitcoin it's
the complete opposite over the past 10
years everything's become a lot cheaper
for people that hold bitcoin
so when you think through uh the sound
money it sounds like you and i agree
that uh that sound money is gonna be
crucial for the future it is that
constant you talked about
uh in financial markets where there
haven't been constants in the past
uh but you've also written about this
idea of a bitcoin black hole effect
uh and this to me is like one of the
most fascinating concepts uh
in the entire market and one that is
heavily misunderstood so talk through
what exactly is the black hole effect
and then how does that apply to bitcoin
yeah sure so it's a couple different
things that i kind of put together in
that piece
the first one was just obviously what we
just talked about the global macro
backdrop of money printing and infinite
qe and now we're seeing ubi
and and the other two things are what we
had mentioned about the over
collateralization
which is kind of accelerating the rate
of coins being pulled off exchanges
and and the third thing i touched on in
that piece was the speculative attack
which was made popular by pierre richard
and that idea
is basically that you're leveraging uh a
bad currency against one
against a hard sound currency and that's
something we've seen
michael saylor with microstrategy do
where they've issued
convertible debt notes most recently at
zero percent which is insane
900 million dollars which results it
should be mentioned that it was over
subscribed to
at zero percent and so what michael
saylor's essentially doing is he's
leveraging the the failing currency
against
an emerging hard sound money which is
bitcoin
and so when you do that i think that the
most fascinating part to me is basically
people are giving you free money
and you're taking it you're converting
it right like when you're talking about
leveraging it you're literally taking a
bad currency that is being devalued
and you're buying a hard currency which
is purchasing powers continue to
increase
yeah exactly and you know i was talking
to preston the other day and he was
telling me you know i think michael
saylor could have actually issued it at
a negative yield
because you know at the rate that that
the fed is driving down interest rates
and
in europe you're seeing negative
interest rates and here we're seeing
negative
interest rates in real terms and
essentially what what people do are
doing that are buying into these
convertible debt notes is
a a they might not be able to get
exposure to bitcoin
uh through other ways um through buying
market price
or uh buying different shares like
grayscale bitcoin trust or something
like that so they're trying to look for
an alternative way to get exposure to it
but in addition with the interest rates
going down
by buying these these uh notes at zero
percent
they essentially will benefit if if
rates go negative that's kind of what
you're seeing in europe
is that people are buying negative
yielding bonds because
they're betting that they that the
yields are going to go further further
negative
and so that could become really
dangerous once that kind of unwinds
and so i think in my opinion that's why
the fed is going to have to continue to
buy
in through the fixed income market and
keep driving these yields down because
the second that they start to reverse
everything is going to unravel so when
you think about the black hole effect
itself
right explain that yeah so it's just the
idea that bitcoin kind of sucks
everything in
and you know every four years the supply
cuts in half
and when you have these cycles we have
these kind of blow off tops and then
through the bottom
every single bottom that we've seen is
further
is higher than the the previous one and
so what you're seeing is this growing
network effect similar to
anything you know facebook or anything
like that but we've never seen that with
a monetary number attached to it so i
think that's why people are really taken
back by
by bitcoin's price movement but these
four-year having cycles will continue
and they'll persist until the year 2140
and so essentially if you can think of
it like a battering ram and it's con
it's continuing to bang against the
legacy financial system
until at some point it's going to break
through and
so there's that aspect of it and then in
addition
right now like i had mentioned the
futures are trading to a premium to the
current spot price
and so if the market starts to identify
the yields that you can get
essentially risk-free through that
process of arbitraging those spreads
and if the market starts to recognize
those yields as
the real risk-free yield you're going to
see a complete re-price of assets
you know particularly stocks they're all
priced based off of risk for yields when
you do a discount cash flow model you
use
treasury yields as your discount rate
and right now that discount rate you
know for the 10 years
i think it's right around hovering
around like 1.5 percent
and if if that thing if the market
starts to identify these big
bitcoin yields which are blowing out to
10 15
plus potentially then you're going to
see a stock market
for example just as a round number if
they blow out to 20 percent
you're going to need to see p p e ratios
go well
under five and right now the average p e
ratio
of the s p is over 34. so you're looking
at a 75 to 80 percent correction in the
stock market if that were to hold true
and not only that but a p e ratio of
five would just match
this risk-free rate right i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna invest in something that
is risk-on that's offering the same
yield as something that has no risk it
would have to be substantially lower
than that
um and the yield that it's offering
would have to be substantially higher
than that risk for yield so you may
actually see
p e ratios go even lower than than five
to you know maybe two
three if we start to see these yields
blow out to twenty plus percent
absolutely and one of the things that's
really fascinating to me is this last
article that you wrote contango and over
collateralization right
we're talking a lot about risk here
we're talking a lot about the financial
performance of other assets but there's
things specifically within the bitcoin
market
uh that are unique um and worth paying
attention to so explain contango and
explain the over collateralization
yeah sure so as we kind of touched on
earlier the futures price is trading at
a premium to spot
and so for people looking to capture
those spreads they have to borrow coins
from an exchange such as block fi and
they have to over collateralize
on that so if they're looking to borrow
fifty dollars
worth of bitcoin they have to put up a
hundred dollars as collateral
that uh hundred dollars is taken by
block fi and and turned into bitcoin to
be held in escrow
and so what happens is as the volatility
of bitcoin increases and the price goes
up more
these spreads get even fatter and it
becomes even more
desirable for different fixed income
investors that
are currently dealing with near negative
yielding
instruments right now and so as these
yields continue to grow
you'll see more people stepping in to
capture those spreads and more
coins being over collateralized and so
it's just accelerating this rate of
coins being pulled off of supply
and so that's the idea of contango that
it's kind of this self-enforcing
positive
feedback loop if you will that the more
coins pulled off exchanges drives the
price higher and volatility higher
which makes the spreads fatter which
makes them more attractive more people
step in
and then the more people are over
collateralizing and
it's just this feedback loop of um
of coins that just continue to be pulled
off of exchanges at this
crazy rate all right so here's the big
question then
is as that happens where do we go in
this cycle is this a
a super cycle that everyone keeps
talking about and we're seeing
you know 500 000 a million dollars uh in
us dollar
kind of exchange value is it no it's
like more like a 150 200
i don't care about the price prediction
necessarily as much as just like
help people understand as that supply uh
and really it's the addressable supply
right the kind of the available supply
continues to trend down what happens to
the price
yeah i mean that's a good question i
would hate not to own bitcoin right now
right
[Laughter]
yeah it's really interesting to see you
know as we had mentioned on kind of at
the beginning of the conversation that
we have never seen this dramatic of a
slope downward in coins being held on
exchanges
and that the supply suffocation going on
that that's just persisting every day i
mean every day i'm checking this
this chart and it's just continually
going down more coins are being pulled
off exchanges
and it's kind of it's kind of hard to
tell exactly what's driving that
um but man i i would be terrified not to
own some bitcoin right now
yeah and well and i think part of what
uh what people are waking up to the fact
is and i i
jokingly talk about it as bitcoins
aren't selling their bitcoin and the
institutions want it so the price has to
go up to accommodate everyone but if you
actually break down what
you know the joke uh and you kind of
melt that away and you say like what
what is the truth in that joke
it basically is the fact that 60 of
coins uh have not moved
in the last you know called year plus uh
and so those are bitcoiners who have
strong hands right there's been hundreds
of percent of appreciation
there's been a 50 drop in a single day
multiple 20 30
corrections along the way and bitcoiners
just aren't selling literally
middle fingers to wall street to the
institutions to everybody i'm not
selling my bitcoin
then you go and you look okay but
there's all these big institutions that
are showing up right new york uh
life uh mass mutual uh every wall street
firm et cetera they're showing up and
they've got billions of dollars and
they're saying we want bitcoin
and so really what you're talking about
is 40 of that 18.6 million bitcoin that
are in circulation
are kind of available for purchase but
even
those are quickly being eaten into
people are taking those off
uh line as well right so you're
basically talking about this like
40 addressable supply that is decreasing
and yet at the same time that the
available supply is decreasing
the demand is increasing and so
naturally what you get is you get this
like
squeeze right it's literally a price
squeeze and when that squeeze happens
you know again it's scary as hell not to
own any bitcoin
yeah absolutely i mean to just basically
go off what you were just saying i mean
you're saying like we like we said you
know supply is going down it
never seen before rates and we're
starting to see demand come in that
we've never s at rates we've never seen
before and money being thrown at this
thing
that we've never you know sizes of money
that we've never seen before
when you're up you know several hundred
percent bitcoin has 200 percent
uh risk adjusted returns on annually you
you don't care about it going down
20 percent you know when
when you can see this on chain as well
if you look at coins that are held
in holders from the last six months last
last year
they kind of sold into this recent dip
they might have got freaked out and sold
it
but when you look at coins that have
addresses that have been holding coins
since
you know 2015 and and further back
they're continuing to accumulate they
haven't sold anything
and it's just you know when you're up
thousands and thousands of percent you
could care less about this little dip
and you understand every time that
there's a dip historically throughout
bitcoin
it's always gone back up it's always
recovered every single all-time high
that you've ever bought
bitcoin has always come and gone past
that
to me it just feels like uh people
who don't pay attention every day to the
level of uh detail and nuance that you
and i do
uh it's very easy to say hey this
thing's wild it's volatile it goes up it
goes down i don't know what's going on
it's a scam it's a ponzi scheme it's
you know worthless it's name your you
know kind of fud
of choice and it ultimately just goes
back to education
right is uh they're just not educated on
the topic to the level
uh of information that you and i are so
i guess my big question is just like
where do you get your information
how do you stay educated and then what
is your process
for taking those inputs and kind of the
consumption that you have
and then turning it out into these
fantastic articles
yeah sure so thanks a lot first of all
but i get a lot of my information just
from different podcasts
in the space uh preston's podcast is
excellent
stefan lavera peter mccormick yours as
well
um and there's several books as well
that you can read i think the bitcoin
standard is the most well known
and then just in general you know just
being on twitter asking questions
twitter's such a cool space you can
get in contact with all these people you
never would have gotten
uh the chance to be able to reach out to
just
you know slide in people's dms and you'd
be surprised how many people are willing
to respond and willing to help you out
and answer questions
so i think you know when when you're
really obsessed with something
learning really doesn't feel like
learning it just kind of feels like fun
to you and and
the further you start to go into this
thing bitcoiners kind of call it the
rabbit hole but
the further you go the the faster you
you begin to kind of be interested in it
and it kind of compounds on itself
the rate that which you you want to
learn i mean if you look at michael
saylor he said
he didn't take a single look at bitcoin
until right after march
after the liquidity crisis and then he
knows more than almost anybody in the
space now and he's only been in it for
for months so it's pretty uh it's pretty
wild
what what is uh kind of the impetus for
why you
enjoy writing is it a way to learn is it
just something you've always done
talk to us a little bit about the
writing itself yeah sure so
there's a lot of really brilliant
writers in the space i think the
one that everybody's familiar with is
robert breedlove he's brilliant but
you know some of robert's articles are
20 30 minute long reads
and for people that are coming into the
space and
these kind of philosophical comparisons
that robert's making bitcoin to
comparing bitcoin to it's just they're
not good for for entry level
bitcoiners that are coming in or or lynn
alden who just put out two brilliant
articles yesterday
these are all kind of higher level
articles and reads for people
that are kind of financially savvy or
have some surface level understanding of
bitcoin so for me especially
being younger and having people
constantly asking me questions but don't
understand anything about finance
um i kind of took it upon myself to kind
of dumb everything down into
really layman's terms and and and
explain things kind of at the surface
level where somebody who doesn't have
any financial understanding can
can uh can kind of make sense of all
this stuff
the other thing as well is that when i
write it really helps me formulate my
own thoughts
i would consider myself more of a slow
thinker i i can kind of sit down and
really soak everything in and then
i think you know i'll sit down for like
an hour and then things will come to me
over time rather than
just thinking of things on the fly so so
that as well i think
i'm much better at articulating things
when i'm when i'm writing and
and uh taking time to kind of think my
thought process out so it's beneficial
for me in that aspect as well
doing a a fantastic job before we get
into the rapid fire questions
uh where can people find you on twitter
or find your writing
yeah sure so i'm on twitter at uh w
clementi
iii i'm the third and then
as well i'm writing for bitcoin magazine
um who just brought me on as an intern
this summer so i'm super excited to be
there
i'll be at uh the bitcoin conference in
june i don't know if you're coming but i
hope
i hope i'll see you there awesome
and then as well i'm writing uh
periodically for uh
bitrar.com b-i-t-r-a-r-a-w-r
they were kind of the ones that uh
originally brought me in and kind of
recognized me
and uh so i owe a great deal of uh
recognition to them for kind of giving
me uh an opportunity to begin writing
and then
that kind of led the way for bitcoin
magazine to bring me on their team as
well so
awesome i asked the same three questions
to everyone before
you could ask me one to finish up the
first is what is the most important book
you've ever read
geez um i would i would say
financially the big debt crisis had to
navigate a big the big debt crisis by
ray dalio that book really breaks down
the you know the the
long and short-term debt cycles
inflationary and deflationary crisis
um the main things that drive those and
then
just just for general life i would say
another ray dalio book
principles by ray dalio that that book
is is
really life-changing at least to me and
i'd recommend it to anybody
those are two uh two great uh
suggestions now we just gotta get ready
to
buy some bitcoin but i think he might be
he's been awfully quiet about it so
he's getting closer he's getting closer
for sure
it's amazing when you read his book you
know he highlights
he highlights everything extremely well
you know ray understands
these things better than anybody but he
thinks that the juan will be the new
reserve currency so i think he's got
everything down pat
except for that and he'll come around
he'll come around soon
i i tend to think so as well uh next
question comes from our friends over at
eight
sleep uh i used to sleep like five or
six hours when i was in college like you
tried to party my face off and basically
uh destroy my body on a uh
on a weekly basis uh but now i sleep on
the eight-sleep thermo-regulated bed
it's freezing cold i sleep like eight or
nine hours and it literally changed my
life
uh what's your sleep schedule and how
has that changed
yeah sure so um when i was at school
last year
i really wasn't sleeping much you know
it's getting maybe four or five hours a
night but now that i'm home
due to code and
because i can't really do anything here
and there's not much going on i've been
i've been getting my hours and i've been
getting seven eight hours a day so
but i have been feeling a lot better
getting more sleep so it's definitely
been something that i'm gonna
keep in my uh habits moving forward yeah
it's crazy to me how well you can go
from basically
school and then you go back home right
and every college kid in america pretty
much is
sitting at home and just itching to get
back you got to get
get back and get the college experience
for sure yeah man i'm ready to go back
in august
i love it uh last question is aliens are
you a believer or a non-believer
no doubt i mean when you just think
about the the probabilities it
just really doesn't make sense that
there wouldn't be any kind of other life
form all the different combinations of
elements and and different things in the
universe and all these different kinds
of planets i mean there's no way that
there hasn't
that has the combinations haven't come
together to make another life form
somewhere else in the giant universe
that we have
absolutely i completely agree all right
you could ask me one question to uh to
wrap us up what you got for me
what would you ask your 18 or i'm sorry
what would you
say to your 18 year old self go bigger
just that's it just go bigger no [ __ ]
fear and uh i think that uh at 18 you're
always kind of trying to figure out
how do i uh how do i make a thousand
dollars right how do i
uh kind of get the next step in the
milestones how do i get
my foot in the door or something like
that but i think that what you start to
realize
is uh uh it's all hard right whether
it's you're trying to make a thousand
dollars or a million dollars if you're
trying to
uh you know buy 10 bitcoin or 100
bitcoin or you know 0.1 of a bitcoin
uh if you're trying to uh get a
internship or get a full-time job like
it's just all hard and so just set your
sites much much higher
and uh and kind of dream bigger and i
think that when you do that
um you're gonna put the same effort into
it but you just get a bigger reward if
you're successful
keep that in mind moving forward man
thanks absolutely all right well listen
you're doing a fantastic job keep it up
i uh really want to make sure that
people kind of understood uh
you know your viewpoint and uh highly
suggest everyone to uh to go read every
time you put something out it's always
enjoyable to read so
keep up the great work and we'll do this
again in the future thanks a lot palm
this is super fun